[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes aux arcades du
lac à montigny le bretonneux signer
ricardo bofill voici le sommaire ricardo
bofill l'architecte de renom est décédé
le 14 janvier dernier il avait pensé les
arcades du lac à montigny le bretonneux
nous reviendrons aussi sur ses autres
réalisations à chéroy de 15 ans maxime
grisard joue du violoncelle et du piano
depuis tout petit il participe
actuellement au world visuel junior en
concours de musique classique portrait à
suivre et enfin la clé des champs salle
de concert à plaisir dévoile sa
programmation
de janvier à juin sept concerts seront
présentés au public
je me trouve aux arcades du lac à
montigny le bretonneux l'architecte
catalan ricardo beau fils qui a imaginé
cet ensemble de logements est décédé le
14 janvier dernier à 82 ans elisabeth
roja le febvre bonjour bonjour vous êtes
architecte urbaniste et directrice au
conseil d'architecturé d'urbanisme et de
l'environnement le daisy ville alors
avant de parler de la renommée un de
ricardo au beau fils et de ses plus
grandes réalisations on va s'attarder
sur l' architecture des arcades du lac
ces architectures arm convoi est ce que
vous pouvez finalement nous la décrire
et
cette architecture on la surnomme le
versailles du peuple c'est ça oui oui
tout à fait alors on a beaucoup de
chance aujourd'hui parce qu'il fait très
beau et c'est une architecture assez
austère celle de résultats de ricardo
bofill on voit ici une architecture
puisé dans l'histoire de l'architecturé
française
c'est une architecture
historiciste c'est à dire que on voit
qu'il reprend des thèmes
2 me à versailles lié aussi au temple
grec à l'architecturé romaine donc c'est
un ensemble assez éclectique et que l'on
peut nommer dans notre jargon
architectural post moderne c'est à dire
qui il réutilise des thèmes qu'il
réinterprète
évidemment avec des matériaux
d'aujourd'hui avec des matériaux des
années 80 de l'architecte des panneaux
moulène et panneaux préfabriqués
de là où une couleur rouge qui est issu
je pense de son histoire puisqu'il est
catalan
alors que l'architecturé de versailles
par exemple est très blanche donc c'est
comme on peut le voir austère parce que
justement c'est assez sombre mais en
même temps ça trappe la lumière c'est
c'est assez étonnant c'est une
architecture
être on peut ne pas l'aimer du tout on
peut l'apprécier on peut y trouver des
qualités
c'est en tout cas une architecture qui
reste très
alors elle est pas du tout sobre elle et
elle est au contraire j'allais dire un
peu grandiloquente mais elle reste en
très bon état au bout de toutes ces
années ou alors on est dans le quartier
de la source de riz et nous avons
demandé aux habitants justement ce
qu'ils pensaient de cette architecture
regardez ici tout le monde peut venir y
prendre un pique nique discuter un peu
faire son sport qu'il s'est vraiment
service va percer plus déçu qu'il soit
décédé si vite mais bon on va le fait
qu'on en parle déjà c'est à dire que et
il va rester un petit peu dans
l'histoire déjà je dirais que c'est un
quartier qui possède une architecture
très spécial
qui a tendance à ressembler au château
de versailles c'est ce que voulait
d'architecte il me semble et ce qui est
très bien c'est que c'est beaucoup
visité c'est très agréable à vivre c'est
très calme avec la pièce d'eau à côté il
y en a plein d'oiseaux migrateurs c'est
un quartier très très calme très
familial en fait on al'avantage que ce
soit complètement piétons donc du coup
pour les enfants c'est idéal j'étais
meilleur rapport qualité prix avait
beaucoup de d'habitabilité à l'intérieur
beaucoup d espace
l'extérieur nous plaisait moyennement
mais mais l'intérieur était vraiment
spacieux donc c'est ça qui nous as tu
rêves
[Musique]
le mans
alors on vient de voir dans le micro
trottoir un habitant parler aussi de
l'intérieur il est qu'il avait un grand
séjour on peut parler un peu de cet
intérieur finalement et/ou où ces
séjours sont sont plutôt
généreuse et généreux c'est fait alors
effectivement à l'époque
la norme des logements et plus
importante qu'aujourd'hui enfin disons
plutôt que les surfaces se sont réduites
parce que les promoteurs réduisent et
puis les gens ont peut-être moins
d'argent pour avoir des surfaces
importantes et j'ai regardé avant
l'émission effectivement les surfaces
des séjours sont de 27 mètres carrés
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est plutôt vain
la norme est encore aujourd'hui les
cuisines sont dans les séjours alors que
là on a huit mètres carrés 9 mètres
carrés de cuisine et 27 m² de séjour
donc c'est des espaces assez spacieux
et ricardo vos films d'ailleurs ne s'est
pas arrêté aux arcades du lac alors ce
que les gens ne savent pas forcément
c'est que quatre ans après il va
réaliser l architecture de 200 autres
logements de l'autre côté du lac à
voisins le bretonneux effectivement il
réalise les temples est que l'on voit
ici qui sont d'une autre architecture
beaucoup plus blanche contrairement à
l'autre dont on parlait tout à l'heure
qui était rouge et
peut-être plus plate c'est à dire avec
moins de modénatures moins
moins d'attrait architectural je dirais
donc on peut donc dire que ricardo beau
fils et l'un des plus importants
architectes de saint quentin en yvelines
en quoi son architecture finalement est
singulière
ah ah elle est singulière parce que on
lui a proposé des ensembles énorme donc
il a réalisé effectivement en france une
dizaine de très très grosses
réalisations
suite aux grands ensembles qui était un
petit peu à l'époque décrié par la
population et c'était la fin des grands
ensembles lui il a fait ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui un architecte qui vient de
sortir un livre
jacques lucan appelle ça des grandes
formes c'est à dire pour pour
différencier avec les grands l'ensemble
des grandes formes ce sont des les
ensembles vraiment très très sympa avec
un nombre de logements très important
ici 364 la 200 aujourd'hui les
opérations sont 50 logements c'est beau
c'est vraiment des très grosses
opérations et puis l'historicisme qui
marque son architecture fait que la
plupart des gens le connaissent grâce à
st alors justement vous parlez de ses
autres réalisations
d'architectes de renommée mondiale en
ile de france il a fait les espaces dab
rasd abraxas à noisy-le-grand fait pas
ou encore la place des colonnes à cergy
pontoise regardez ces cinq projets
majeurs
[Musique]
et
e
[Musique]
alors viens de voir ses projets
d'envergure si on revient à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines finalement il
n'y avait pas que ricardo beau fils qui
était qui est vraiment célèbre quand on
parle d'architecturé a bien sûr dans les
villes nouvelles il ya toujours des
célébrités qui sont convoqués et alors
celui qui me vient en premier c'est
renzo piano qui a construit avec richard
rodgers qui vient de mourir d'ailleurs
beaubourg le centre pompidou et qui a
construit dans la ville nouvelle à
guyancourt les halles de thomson qui ne
sont plus en activité aujourd'hui mais
qui vont être
réutilisés j'en suis très contente parce
que j'ai eus vrai aussi à cela
réutiliser dans le projet autour de la
gare de la nouvelle gare du grand paris
express de guyancourt et va très bien
merci beaucoup pour tout ses
explications il avait trop ja le faire
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
oh
m
[Musique]
et on ouvre une page musicale à présent
maxime grisard jeunes à charroi de 15
ans jouait du violoncelle et du piano
depuis son plus jeune âge il participe
aux oies de vie jeunes juniors un
concours de musique classique focus sur
son histoire
[Musique]
je m'appelle médecine reiser j'ai 15 ans
je joue de lui lancer les du piano le
troisième mouvement concerto pour
violoncelle de dvorak n'a plus de secret
pour maxime à seulement 15 ans le
violoncellistes et pianistes se produit
régulièrement en france et à l'étranger
il a gagné plusieurs concours dont la
catégorie instruments de l'émission
prodige de france 2 qui l'a fait
connaître au grand public et a déjà
enregistré un disque chez warner
classique j'ai commencé le piano à 7 ans
au conservatoire h/f et après un an plus
tard j'ai commencé le violoncelle
qu' il y avait on avait un disque de
avec des oeuvres de rachmaninov koei
j'aimais beaucoup inscrit à neuf ans au
conservatoire de saint germain en laye
il le passe en seulement quatre ans le
garçon qui ne vient pourtant pas d'une
famille musicienne s'entraîne jusqu'à 35
heures par semaine un talent et du
travail qui lui font vivre de beaux
moments j'aime bien faire à des concerts
joués pour la région et tout ça va faire
plaisir c'est pour ça qu'on fait de la
musique quoi rostro il avait joué devant
le mur de berlin en 1989 après geste
après la chute j'avais envie de faire
comme hymne du coup je suis allé à
berlin j'ai joué devant un mur et puis
j'aimais bien bas les gens et lister
content lui donner un peu d'argent et du
coup je m'achetais des partitions je
jouais dans la rue il ya des musiciens
italiens qui est moins écouté pendant
plus d'une heure et après ils sont venus
me voir et m'ont invité es fin des
concerts en italie il représente
actuellement la france howard visionnent
musique conteste dans la catégorie
junior un concours en ligne avec une
finale prévue fin février à vienne pas
ça au final ce serait qu'on pourra jouer
avec marquez s'est mais quel est le
grand prix après on peut
participer à des concerts et ça c'est
cool vous pouvez voter gratuitement pour
maxime sur le site de world vision
jusqu'au 29 janvier
[Musique]
d'autres spectacles sont aussi à
découvrir à l'auditorium de la batterie
un groupe franco argentin revisite le
répertoire d'astor piazzolla à
l'occasion de son centenaire si vous
êtes un amateur de tango piazzolla 2021
est à voir sur la scène samedi 29
janvier à 20h30 à la même date et même
heure maxime le forestier se produira
sur la scène du théâtre simone signoret
de conflans sainte honorine sept ans
après son dernier album il revient avec
eux par être ou ne pas être une dizaine
de nouveaux titres
la clé des champs et salles de concerts
à plaisir dévoile sa programmation
de janvier à juin sept concerts sont
présentés au public le 1er révèle le
chanteur cure de rue sanofi du steak
dans le cadre du festival au fil des
voix dimanche 30 janvier on en parle
avec frédéric poletto le directeur de la
clé des gens
[Musique]
il s'agit du festival au fil des voix
qui est organisée à un pari à partir de
la fin janvier jusqu'à la mi-février
nous accueillons l'avant première
nous avons noué un partenariat avec ses
festivals pour
accueillir de gros artistes musiques du
monde là en l'occurrence nous recevrons
un artiste kurdes à la clé des champs en
configuration assise
[Musique]
on va avoir du ragga du métal y aura de
la chanson française donc voilà on va
dans plusieurs directions tout en
gardant une identité qu'on va essayer de
développer
ou sera mesurée avec
[Musique]
biga ranx à la fiche belle artiste
français ragga se déroulera le 9 avril
on a eu la confirmation ce matin
l'occasion d'y revenir et ensuite on a
le 18 février une soirée 100%
brésilienne avec le théâtre coluche à
plaisir la clé des champs c'est aussi
les penseurs hors les murs on appelle ça
les hanches en est donc là on accueille
chao salua en première partie de flavia
coelho et c'est la fin de ses 7,8
culture merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez vous la semaine prochaine dans un
autre lieu culturel yves binois bonne
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]